[Musica]
dotata di una presa molto semplice che
ci riguarda tutti che come usiamo le
parole è un po la mia fissazione nel
senso che io passo la vita a parlare di
parole ea cercare di usarle bene e prima
di tutto ho provato queste cose su di me
la prima cosa che mi voglia dire questa
non ci sentiamo mai abbastanza
ma il linguaggio è la cosa che ci rende
umani noi siamo gli unici animali che
hanno il potere della parola
pensate agli animali che avete in casa
gatto cane
sapete bene che il gatto non dice sono
mia oh
il cane non dice solo baù ma il gatto
dice un sacco di milano diversi il cane
un sacco di bau diversi eppure nessun
animale per quanto intelligente riesce
usare uno strumento sofisticato come il
linguaggio umano
il professor chomsky in un'intervista
molto buffa rilasciata aligi che è il
rapper inventato da sasha baron cohen
risponde così alla domanda che ti fa il
rapper che è professore ma lei che ha 80
anni che si occupa di lingua non si è
stancato sempre di parlare delle lingue
del linguaggio e lo risponde così noi in
realtà no perché la lingua è la
caratteristica nucleare che ci rende
esseri umani
noi non possiamo fare a meno delle
parole eppure siccome la lingua madre
ce l'abbiamo da sempre praticamente
gratis da quando nasciamo non ci
pensiamo mai abbastanza
eppure ogni parola che noi scegliamo ha
un sacco di usi cern ha un sacco di cose
la prima cosa che noi facciamo con la
realtà e con la lingua è questa
descriviamo la realtà che ci circonda
pensate bene noi parliamo della realtà e
deco edifichiamo la realtà mettendola
dei cartellini e ci riusciamo a
intendere perché siamo d'accordo su
questi cartellini potrei citare un
famoso sketch di aldo giovanni e giacomo
che forse conoscete a quello della
cadrega carega per chi è veneto
come funzionali che due persone mettono
alla prova un'altra per capire se fanno
parte della stessa tribù perché non c'è
accordo sul significato della parola
cadrega infatti aldo prende una mela e
dice buona questa cadrega gli altri
capiscono che lui è un estraneo
quindi a noi serve la lingua per
descrivere ciò che ci circonda
vi faccio notare un'altra cosa siccome
la realtà cambia di continuo è in
evoluzione perenne allora anche la
lingua cambia di continuo
non è detto che questo ci piaccia ma su
questo torniamo tra un attimo la lingua
ci serve per comunicare
ovviamente tra di noi e come vi dicevo
prima
oltre che comunicare e basta la lingua
definisce la mia tribù quindi io
identifico le persone che appartengono
alla stessa tribù noi pensiamo di essere
andati avanti rispetto al concetto
tribale ma così non è
siamo ancora estremamente tribali come
esseri umani e allo stesso tempo
identifico le persone che non fanno
parte della mia tribune quindi mi
permette di individuare gli altri
pensate allo sketch che vi ho raccontato
prima la lingua serve per una terza cosa
molto importante che forse è quella che
ci interessa di più
ogni parola che usiamo è letteralmente
un atto di identità cioè io dico agli
altri chi sono faccio una dichiarazione
quand'è che ci si innamora veramente di
una persona ci si può invaghire
dell'aspetto fisico ma la cosa veramente
che ci colpisce sono le cose che dice e
in che modo dice quelle cose
ovviamente essendo il linguaggio la
proprietà nucleare delle persone noi ci
innamoriamo di questo cioè della parte
più profonda della persona infatti
spesso ci si innamora che di brutti
perché non è così importante
l'importante alla fine è quello che dice
[Musica]
poi a che altro serve la lingua
ovviamente se io racconto delle cose di
me quelle parole le devo pensare bene
perché che cosa voglio che gli altri
capiscano dei meno ve lo chiedete mai
quando per esempio rilasciato un
pezzettino di frase su facebook in
pubblico che cosa penseranno gli altri
di me leggendo quella cosa che ho
scritto
poi magari me ne pento e voglio
cancellare ma come sapete tutti esiste
dio screenshot e quindi anche cancellare
un po utopia dice searle non è possibile
pensare con chiarezza se non si è capaci
di parlare e scrivere con chiarezza cioè
il nostro modo di comunicare spiega
anche agli altri quanto è chiaro il
nostro pensiero
quanto siamo in grado di concepire un
pensiero lineare perché se il pensiero
lineare allora siamo anche in grado di
veicolare in maniera lineare
un po quello che diceva nanni moretti lo
ricordate
siamo sempre quel campo lì ovviamente le
lingue tutte hanno molte più parole di
quelle strettamente necessarie
facciamo un attimo di statistica
l'italiano ha dalle 300 mila al milione
di parole è difficile fare una stima
precisa perché dipende da quali parti
per esempio dei dialetti consideriamo
parte anche del lessico italiano una
persona mediamente colta diciamo alla
fine degli studi superiori conosce circa
35 40 mila parole ma non le usiamo tutte
noi nelle nostre attività quotidiane ce
la caviamo con circa 2.000 parole molte
di più sono quelle che sentiamo e quindi
conosciamo perché per esempio i media le
usano spesso non lo so penitenziario
meteorologico e via dicendo
abbiamo un patrimonio sterminato di
parole e secondo me più o meno tutti
intuiamo abbastanza chiaramente che le
parole non sono tutte uguali
una parola può essere un
lascio una parola può essere un
proiettile
allora il modo più facile di
identificare le parole è fare una lista
di quelle brutte
pensate che è quello che si fa spesso
online
io vi faccio una black list di parolacce
e quindi se una persona usa quelle
parolacce
io non pubblico il post quel post viene
censurato ma è sempre così
pensate una parola come tutti
quanti rabbrividiscono se la dice un
bianco in senso offensivo nei confronti
di un afroamericano è chiaro che è una
parola brutta ma avete notato che per
esempio i rapper afroamericani le usano
nei loro testi per auto definirsi perché
è un modo di sottolineare black power
quindi neanche una parola brutta come
nei chrome può essere stigmatizzata a
priori in realtà dipende dal contesto in
cui quella parola viene usata ma
facciamo qualche esempio più vicino a
noi potrebbe essere un ortaggio
finocchio oppure un modo molto
maleducato di riferirsi al omosessuale
usiamo una frase entro in una mensa e
dico oggi a pranzo ci sono i finocchi mi
sto riferendo al piatto che
probabilmente molti di voi amano fino a
oggi fanno bene drenanti entrò nella
stessa mensa c'è un tavolo di attivisti
lgbt e oggi a pranzo ci sono i finocchi
stessa frase
ma cosa cambia l'intento comunicativo
che faccio of lago a priori la parola
finocchio perché è negativa no perché a
questo punto dovrei censurare metà del
mio lessico cagna cagna nel corso degli
anni da cane femmina ha assunto un altro
significato che forse vi ricordate
perché è diventato famoso anche grazie
alla serie televisiva quello prima di
attrice scadente e poi appunto usato in
senso
negativo nei confronti delle donne
talmente questa parola ha assunto un
significato negativo che i padroni di
cani femmine preferiscono fare delle
circo locuzioni non dicono porto fuori
la cagna se no qualcuno potrebbe pensare
alla moglie ma piuttosto di cola canetta
la canina la qana ci auto censuriamo
perché sennò uno potrebbe pensare male
visto disco con la terza parola signora
come signora negativo allora se ne parlo
coi ragazzi ragazzi mi dicono sì signora
è negativo nel senso che magari una
giovane sarebbe una signorina allora
chiamata signora si offende ma è molto
più sottile quello che vi faccio notare
a me è successo diverse volte
unica donna istanza di uomini tutti i
professionisti
l'uomo che entra nella sala chiama
dottor i maschi e signora la donna sa
che io di solito reagisco piuttosto male
quindi per finora parola che in realtà
voglia dire positiva come signora se
usata in un certo senso potrebbe
diventare non dico offensiva ma comunque
perlomeno dare fastidio a qualcuno
allora capite che non basta la lista
nera non basta la lista nera non basta
la censura ma ci vuole una cosa
fondamentale che è la nostra
intelligenza
dobbiamo pensarci noi anche perché le
parole non sono solo parole
pensate a un'altra cosa che fanno le
parole le parole compiono azioni se io
sono un professore ho il potere di
promuovere o bocciare uno studente se io
sono un sindaco o il potere di sposare
le persone se io sono un medico ho il
potere di dichiarare la nascita e la
morte avete presente nei medical drama
la persona non è morta finché una
persona un'annata persona nel ruolo
giusto non ha dichiarato il decesso
cioè noi compiamo arti con le parole
compiamo atti di continuo pensate all
atto supremo giurare giurare una cosa
serissima ma ha delle conseguenze
pratiche se io spergiuro
in realtà no ma fra le persone c'è una
c'è di patto per cui se io giuro penso
veramente a quella cosa lì non giuro con
leggerezza anche se in realtà sappiamo
tutti che nessuno ci fulminerà questo è
il potere della parola
allora in un mondo così sovraccarico di
parole perché è vero che è sovraccarico
siamo circondati continuamente da parole
io vi invito a fare una cosa
riprendiamoci il potere della parola
giusta questa è una cosa che possiamo
fare tutti perché non implica imparare
cose strane implica a prendere in mano
una competenza che abbiamo tutti che è
quella della parola e usarla meglio vi
do tre consigli in questo senso la prima
coltivare il dubbio noi viviamo in
un'era che a causa della quantità di
informazioni presenti ci dà l'illusione
della conoscenza
ovviamente conoscere non è googlare
conoscere qualcosa di molto più
approfondito
allora noi giorno dopo giorno in
qualsiasi settore della conoscenza
dobbiamo chiederci i limiti delle cose
che sappiamo quanto poco so quanto poco
so di tutta l'immensità di informazioni
che mi circonda
e questo vale anche per la lingua ogni
giorno io se conosco 35.000 parole su un
milione
è normale che io ogni giorno possa
incontrare parole che non conosco allora
davanti a quelle parole io avrò un
impresa sensazione di fastidio perché io
voglio certezze nella vita gli esseri
umani vogliono certezze
i cambiamenti le cose che non conosciamo
ci spaventano però almeno in campo
linguistico è facile risolvere il
problema vado su un vocabolario ma oggi
è ancora più facile posso googlare ma
alla fine la cosa è la stessa cioè
incontro una parola che non conosco vi
faccio un esempio dal gennaio di
quest'anno gelicidio gelicidio ha creato
un sacco di scontento molti hanno
pensato che fosse una parola nuova un
neologismo è una parola del 1360 quindi
a 700 anni e allora come mai non la
conoscevo perché ognuno di noi conosce
solo una piccola parte di tutto il
lessico che abbiamo a disposizione
quindi la prima cosa è il dubbio che è
secondo perché l'unico modo di aumentare
la conoscenza e sapere di non sapere
nel momento in cui siamo convinti di
sapere tutto quello che ci serve
la nostra capacità di imparare cose
nuove si atrofizza prima cosa seconda
possiamo riflettere il tempo di un
respiro in realtà è semplicissimo perché
perché ne abbiamo la facoltà
abbiamo un po all'illusione di doverci
muovere sempre di essere sempre di corsa
di non avere il tempo di pensare alle
cose ma non è vero
anche quando abbiamo voglia di fare un
post su facebook per fare un esempio
possiamo sempre fermarci 10 secondi a
pensare a quello che vogliamo veramente
dire riprendiamoci il lusso di
riflettere su quello che stiamo per
immettere indiciamo del mondo che ci
circonda
quel micro particella d'informazione
pensiamoci un attimo di più non è
difficile e poi un terzo consiglio
altrettanto semplice quando non siamo
competenti e non sappiamo le cose cose
che succede molto spesso possiamo sempre
scegliere il silenzio
noi viviamo nella società che è abituata
a polarizzarsi su tutto e invece a volte
si può scegliere di non dire nulla anche
perché se io dico le cose sbagliate
occorre che ci ricordiamo che le cose
che abbiamo digitato soprattutto
rimangono ci rimangono attaccate e
contribuiranno alla creazione della
nostra personalità online
vogliamo veramente dire questa cosa che
poi rimane lì attaccata a noi come una
specie di cartaccia che abbiamo immesso
nel mondo quindi come vedete le cose
sono semplici dubbio riflessione
silenzio alla fine è buffo perché in
qualche modo sono tre richieste che non
riguardano direttamente la lingua ma
delle quali la lingua è una conseguenza
alla fine di tutto questo
vorrei farvi notare una cosa queste
competenze non sono immediate occorre
lavorarci tanto
è quello che io chiamo bisogna essere
contadini della lingua perché che cosa
fanno i contadini
forse voi avete presente i contadini si
impegnano giorno dopo giorno non si
stancano mai sanno che dal momento in
cui di stato nel campo al momento in cui
cresce la piantina passa molto tempo
passa un sacco di tempo
bisogna proprio che si impegnino tanto
allora lo riassunta così è la
conseguenza di fatica sudore costanza
resilienza e anche fiducia in sé è
questa piantina qui che alla fine ha
bucato anche l'asfalto non occorre per
forza essere delle spugne magari siamo
più simili all'asfalto
ma la conoscenza è ancora più resiliente
di noi e se diamo una chance potrebbe
andare a finire così
grazie
[Applauso]